this video is brought to you by keeps
this is the climax to the orankar arc
and you know what I'm proud of you guys
last week's feature length video had
some praise had some criticism but you
guys were cool with all of it this is
great will this week be the same what
did I think about it well I'm not gonna
give it away this time so with this
week's material I ask you in the
immortal words of High School Musical 2.
the answer is I don't [ __ ] know
because something really weird happens
immediately following last week's
material where the chapters I thought we
were going to get were going to take us
to the finale instead take us 110 years
into the past so I guess it's time for a
flashback and to be honest I'm always
excited when we get some juicy
substantial flashbacks to sink our teeth
into so let's dive into it I'm totally
not Mark and this is my review of
bleach's short turn back the pendulum
flashback and everything that comes
after
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
so in the last section I mentioned how
urahara was a bit of an enigma to me
particularly after it was revealed that
he and Mr Kurosaki had some sort of
shared history and understanding
additionally during that introductory
portion we were also introduced to
another group called the Visas with
predominant characters like Shinji and
he already to name but a few prior to
all of this we had only been aware of
two sides the good and the world the
evil or at least that's how it's
depicted so far beside if Ichigo and his
allies versus The Mysterious Eisen and
his lackeys as they tried to overthrow
the current world order the addition of
these two other factions with the
Wizards and Mr kisuke's group offer
other points of view by which we can try
to make sense of the world this story is
taking place within and hopefully I hope
add Nuance to the ending here that just
because bleach is depicted artistically
as black and white it does its best work
when operating within the gray areas of
human nature it's precisely why ichigo's
inner conflict is so captivating and
it's precisely why Eisen went undetected
allowed to plot and scheme for decades
and decades and so because this is where
my head is at and where I pray The Story
Goes you can imagine that I was very
excited when I discovered that this
flashback offered not only a history of
Mr kisuke or urhara but also a history
of Shinji hiori and many other folks
that now call themselves visors
[Music]
this is the Curious verbiage that leads
us into easily the most unique part of
the story since its Inception over 300
chapters deep and well over halfway into
the current Arc we are hurled with
hundred years into the past to take a
sneak peek at the inner workings of
certain characters and how they came
into being the way we understand them
today this was very strange to see to
say the least the majority of this
Series has been told through a rather
consistent point of view normally Ichigo
and without him in the story it still
managed to feel like bleach and
oftentimes that can be quite difficult
to pull off instead of each go this
section largely focuses on the origins
morality and history surrounding kisuke
urahara as he gets promoted from a
warden of a rather dubious preemptive
prison for potentially dangerous souls
to a captain of 12th company there's a
very easy to appreciate quality to this
flashback that none of the past parts of
the story have offered us purely by
virtue of what it is it allows us this
abstract chance to see established
characters as we've never seen them
before from Miss yuruichi as the captain
of second company and a very young
byakya prior to his Ascension in that
society and countless other familiar
faces from past arcs however that simply
tickles a romantic and nostalgic part of
my brain and so I figured it was a
distraction to what could be
communicated during this flashback
amidst a sea of distractions you could
easily be fooled and this is a
philosophy or approach many authors take
when trying to pull the bull over their
reader's eyes and when it comes to
flashbacks that feature and put focus on
a large number of characters I normally
ask myself what makes this specific date
that we've flashed back into so
significant why not one week prior or
one week after this and when you ask
yourself that question you find yourself
asking a very useful and more focused
second question what happens on this day
that can't happen on any other day the
answer to that might be obvious it's the
day urahara accepts his promotion as the
captain however it's also the
integration of another prominent albeit
as a yet underused character Keen or Jin
or whatever his name is a young kid
presented to us as a sociopathic killer
and one that we're obviously familiar
with from Soul Society this is also his
first day working beneath another Eisen
as he starts to build his Empire around
him these are the two stories that are
intertwined in some way and so for me
the mystery presented in this tale
wasn't so much who was responsible for
the sudden disappearance of certain
civilians and Soul Reapers later on
though that was creepy but instead it is
how these two plot threads between
urahara and Eisen were connected so
let's explore that right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is advice that Shinji offers
following his first day on the job it's
evident that kisuke isn't a natural-born
leader and is filled with his own
self-doubt it's cool to see Shinji
participate in this segment knowing
where he eventually ends up a casualty
of the brutal nature of Eisen
there's a portion of this flashback that
takes part in the prison that's honestly
an interesting ruffle to this short
story that concerns the motivations of
otahada particularly when it comes to
his work at least his past work known as
the maggot Nest before becoming a
captain urahara was awarded in a prison
facility built to contain potentially
dangerous individuals before they
committed crimes the pool of folks that
would be put into this would be chosen
from the 13 companies of the Soul
Society if the opportunity presented
itself that on its own is crazy however
one of the folks held there was
kurutsuchi making the current situation
all the more crazy seeing as we know
where he ends up today approaching
kurusuchi in the depths of a cell
designed to detain him urahara expresses
that he wants to start a research and
development organization within 12th
company and once could atsuchi to be
assistant director with his final offer
basically making him a de facto leader
if he urahara was to ever die or leave
this occurs around the same time Eisen
asked gene or Gene to take out a third
seed and thus sets the stage for the SEC
second half of this flashback
if you're a fan of this channel in my
analytics or anything to go by you're
most likely a male approaching an age
where male patent baldness is starting
to become a concern unfortunately two of
three of you will experience it by the
time you're 35 and that can be pretty
damn devastating thankfully that's where
keeps comes in they offer substantiated
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth if you pick up a
subscription you'll gain access to their
24 7 team of Expert Medical advisors
who'll support you with whatever hair
goals you have whether they be hair loss
prevention hair growth stimulation or
simply bringing your hair into a
healthier State whatever the need you
have unlimited and personalized contact
with your prescribing doctor throughout
the year it is extremely convenient and
that extends to the products themselves
all the treatment plans are delivered
straight to your door and typically at
around half the price of a traditional
Pharmacy with handy refill reminders
it's easier than ever to stay on top of
things the majority of keeps customers
have noticed results within the first
six months of starting treatment so if
you're ready to see how hair loss stops
with keeps head over to keeps.com
forward slash not Mark or click the link
in the description to receive 50 off
your first order again that's
k-e-e-p-s.com forward slash not mark
nine years later
it's here that Eisen decides to bring to
the attention of the class that quite a
few of rukongai's residents have
disappeared in the last month the ninth
company investigates and once their
discover bush is filled with garments of
10 Soul Reapers after saving a young kid
called Shuhei the fact that this little
kid is asked his specific name means I
assume he'll be a significant character
once this flashback concludes because in
this he really doesn't matter so I
wonder why he would even give us that
Exposition meanwhile urahara is
continuing his work with GI guys that
might be able to Aid this very problem
but since he orid his second in command
to scope out the area instead while on
Route 9th company gets obliterated thus
alerting all back at base to what just
occurred in response to this urahara
asked for permission to Aid her but is
denied naturally he protests as he
doesn't want his assistant Captain to
die but that's when yoruichi chimes in
she tells urahara to cool down and to
not dishonor hiori by losing faith in
her abilities and to that I say uh you
do know another company Captain seems to
have been killed here right whatever
about not talking back to superiors and
maintaining cohesion in a tight spot
this feelings-based excuse presented by
yoroichi feels like a big cope If Ever I
did hear one but anyway enough Preamble
hiori is saved by Shinji at the last
moment so around now I'd like to talk
about how this Arc ties into the themes
of the greater aranca Arc and it's
actually integrated in a way I didn't
notice or anticipate making its reveal
by Eisen all the more satisfying as a
reader recontextualizing a lot of what I
thought came before in the process it's
about trust and all the trappings that
come with it The Good The Virtuous and
the bad something I didn't mention
towards the beginning of this video was
that there was a third significant event
that took place that day 110 years ago
alongside Jean's graduation and
urahara's promotion it too involved
these characters however there was a
third member a third participant a third
person that facilitated the ending and
overall message of this Arc and that
person is Shinji all right
the mystery or surprise element
delivered for this flashback for me was
never the reveal that Eisen was behind
it all and managed to manipulate the
others such that he would get away with
it we always knew that he would because
he ultimately does this is the nature of
dramatic irony in literature and Kubo is
aware of that so if he's not trying to
surprise us with eisen's reveal as the
man behind all of this then what well
it's actually more abstract than that
it's how trust can be interpreted
offering up the driving philosophical
footnote that crafted the perfect
environment for this event to take place
one that destroyed Shinji enabled Eisen
and led to urahara's banishment trust is
a phrase thrown around a number of times
in this short flashback koraku suggests
to urohara that he ought to trust and
have more patience is such an example
however this is the arc that illuminated
for us the exact drawback to not showing
trust and Eisen explains exactly why to
his former Captain Shinji as he laid
there before him he says because you
didn't trust me you maintained a certain
distance from me you never opened
yourself up you never tried to get to
know me this is why you never saw the
truth even when I replaced myself with a
complete stranger that is a really
interesting direction to take this theme
in and not what I honestly saw coming
when that ties not only ichigo's current
struggle into the picture with Shinji
and urahara but one that unilaterally
ties eisen's very existence into that
theme's framework he's the result of
this lack of trust Shinji said he chose
to keep Eisen close in order to keep an
eye on him but in reality Eisen could
have chosen to deny that very promotion
to become an assistant similar to how
others have done so in the past or
earlier in the story so in a sense Eisen
was the one in control he chose Shinji
because he offered him the perfect
opportunity to succeed the emotional
distance Shinji put up against Eisen
acting as the perfect environment for
him to curate his plan behind the scenes
it's an outstanding narrative twist that
even alluded to earlier in the arc with
shinji's very advice he gave to urahara
foreign
[Music]
trust Isn't So straightforward in this
world it has consequences and it opens
you up to being hurt however in the same
way that he already mentioned the
urahara that the philosophy surrounding
his former prison was crazy that the
facility too worked on a no tolerance
policy when it came to the prisoners who
hadn't yet committed crimes there was no
trust there removing trust can for sure
be there for a reason perhaps you were
hurt perhaps you wish to protect Society
or perhaps you want to shoulder all the
work for yourself but at the end of the
day this short flashback highlights
through eisen's rise in success that
there exists benefits to altruistic
trust that just go undetected now
following this I was a little
disappointed but just FYI it's because
I'm a giant baby and because I thought I
knew something that was going to happen
but didn't actually end up happening
okay so Shinji and the others just
started holifying right that's great
it's at this moment urahara interrupts
and saves the day before Eisen says
something cryptic about urhara being the
man that he thought he was and then
leaves now I knew urahara was going to
make the save eventually he did leave to
do just that but I thought hi Yori was
going to be one of the only ones to make
the save as a holified Masked Warrior I
remembered back towards her introduction
we were told that she was one of the
fastest to adapt to that form so I
thought this high-stake situation would
have been an incredible place for it to
occur and for that to then transition to
urahara save but oh well I guess this is
fine following this the status quo
shifts to something much more familiar
to us we learned that urahara created
the hogyoku he's exiled Shinji and his
allies end up in their own situation and
yoruchi sacrifices her standing within
the soul Society for what she thinks is
the right thing to do which is a nice
change from where she stood pertaining
to this sort of insubordination earlier
in the story with the final note that
this flashback enzyme being from Shinji
as he feels as though he owes urahara
and Eisen for what he has become there's
a Nuance to this story that's emerging
one that's no longer a two-sided Affair
but one being approached from multiple
angles and overall I really enjoyed this
short flashback
[Music]
we're finally here time to dig into the
real meat and potatoes of this Arc the
part we've been building up to for the
last 150 chapters so what were my
general thoughts well they are neither
entirely positive or entirely negative
there are aspects of this finale I
thought were really well delivered and
honestly brilliantly delivered I thought
the story being told was fascinating and
I thought the artwork above all else was
consistently fun to read though that's
nothing new with Kubo before I specify
what parts I loved and what specifically
I saw as a slip in quality I'd like for
us to appreciate that I've taken the
time over my career to criticize long
stories like one piece Naruto and Dragon
Ball all these stories like bleach are
not perfect and I think there are
serious problems with this Arc that I
personally think had they been rectified
I would consider this the strongest Arc
overall however I think it might have
fallen short of that though I'm still
not entirely certain I'm collecting my
thoughts on this so let's explore a
little more and I'll give you my final
verdict at the end of the video so what
are my thoughts on the beginning of this
final section
[Music]
for the vast majority of this section
the plot is fractured between two
scenarios or points of view the main
crew of Ichigo oruhime uru and Rukia in
the world of hueco Mundo and of course
the Now new scene of fake karakura Town
defended by the soul society's best from
the tyrannical and now terrifyingly
powerful Eisen both of these sections
have their ups and their downsides and
overall I think both came out delivering
more good than bad let's start off by
covering some of fake karakora's opening
and draw attention to by far by single
biggest issue with this story and yes I
think it hurts the story in a
substantial and significant manner
however I'm only going to point out this
once in pointing out this issue with
bleach I am not simultaneously putting
Dragon Ball Naruto and one piece on
their own pedestals above it I have
dedicated large sections of my past
reviews to criticizing what I consider
to be very substantial pacing issues in
one piece as well as criticize its
layout work in the manga I've even made
some very damning criticisms of Dragon
Balls Buu saga and with the series
writing in general I mean it is true the
dragon balls do take away a lot of the
stakes in that very series does that
mean I don't love each of those stories
absolutely not every series has their
own unique issues and wild bleach I
believe has issues here it's better I
think than other Series in other areas
so what specifically is the issue I have
with bleach there are too many fights
that stop the progression of the story
in its tracks and this is an issue
because I genuinely really enjoy the
story of the aranca arc but to me it
feels like Kubo consistently gets in his
own way to make sure I had the best
faith argument I could muster for this
very argument over the last few weeks
I've taken the time to speak to a few
friends of mine who really and truly
love the bleach series to help process
my thoughts to sharpen my criticisms in
a precise Manner and to learn what
people who do like this section
specifically love about it and what they
love are other characters they love
spending time in this world and with
these individuals and this is the case
whether they be secondary tertiary or
background players because they love
learning more about this world and the
history of the individuals that populate
these pages and let me tell you I have
no issue with that answer it's a really
good answer when I personally agree with
too I've even said as much myself that
character writing is kubo's strongest
trait as a writer that scene where
Orihime says goodbye to Ichigo before
she's taken away to hueco Mundo is
genuinely heartbreaking in the most
brilliant of ways however I think
there's a distinction to make here an
important one and that is World building
in storytelling is very important it
helps the world feel alive but it is not
more important than the plot World
building serves the story and if it gets
in the way of it that's where I
personally start to have problems bleach
as a manga is a Shonen story and Shonen
is a genre that uses fighting to propel
the plot forward oh by the way I'm gonna
say Shonen a lot in this next section
but when I say it I want you to know
that I mean battle Shonen specifically
Shonen that focuses and tells a story
through battle so whenever I say Shonen
I mean battle Shonen okay cool bye
similarly to how Mysteries use the
Enigma of the plot to guide our
curiosity or how romance uses
interpersonal relationships and
emotional conversation to walk us
through their stories Shonen in turn
uses fights for that very purpose and
this is honestly out of necessity so
much time in a Shonen is spent fighting
it of course needs to utilize this time
to push the plot forward to help
illustrate what exactly I'm getting at I
have two great examples of fights
propelling the plot forward and the
first one is Raditz versus Goku and
Piccolo from Dragon Ball Z's Saiyan Saga
despite the specific issues Dragon Ball
has when it comes to fights propelling
the story forward Akira toriyama's
approach is phenomenal and it makes for
a very Snappy story as a result and how
does this fight achieve this by making
it crucial to understanding the story
moving forward without this fight the
ark just can't work simply because it
serves a ton of narrative purposes it
establishes what Gohan is capable of
acts as an important piece of
development for Piccolo that facilitates
his section of the arc with Gohan in its
entirety it kills Goku setting him on
his journey to Otherworld and it
establishes what the goal of the arc is
to stop the incoming Sands that we also
learn in this very fight are stronger
than Raditz himself and due to it
carrying all of this narrative weight I
genuinely think it's an almost perfect
example of a Shonen fight propelling the
plot forward and even if you want me to
go through the smaller fights in the arc
like those that occur with the likes of
Napa once they arrive a ton of that is
used to establish who these villains are
which becomes important very soon after
and perhaps the most important aspect of
this Arc as well were exposed to how far
Gohan still has has to go mentally
before he can truly help his team and as
we see later this aspect this Exposition
for him in the story became vital for us
to both understand and appreciate what
he offers to the climax for without him
things would have turned out very
differently for Goku and that's just one
dimension of this fight bleach however
seems to do the opposite of this when
characters other than Ichigo are taking
part in a fight where it would be
impossible for the Saiyan Saga to make
sense without raditz's fight there are
dozens of fights in this Arc and that's
being generous where it feels like if I
removed them all that would be lost
would be the personality and history of
the secondary and background characters
involved and unfortunately that has no
effect on the story of this Arc and it
should and while yes that does build up
the world around it it doesn't do
anything for the story which makes it by
default filler flavor and Canon filler
is never a good thing but what am I
suggesting as an alternative am I
suggesting to remove these fights not
necessarily what I am asking for is if
you are going to spend time with all of
these wonderful characters make it
necessary to the story instead of
getting in the way now my second example
of a fight that propels the plot forward
also manages to splice in the
personalities of the characters we all
know and love while making that a
pivotal part of the narrative and that
fight happens to be my favorite fight
from one piece Luffy versus Usopp from
the water 7 Arc I use the Dragon Ball
example to explain how one can use
fights to drive a narrative so let's use
one piece to demonstrate how you can
exposit the mental state of characters
through fighting and how those very
exposited personalities can create the
fuel that pushes the story in a specific
Direction and funnily enough it's for
that very reason this is my favorite
fight in all of One Piece on the surface
this isn't a fight that's carried by the
weight of the physical task standing in
front of Luffy but instead the emotional
baggage it represents the main plot
thread most people recall from this
section of the story concerns that of
Robin and her now famous declaration to
live however the story that usop
represents complements that main plot
thread perfectly faced with a
deteriorating condition of the going
Mary and the decision Luffy and the
others have made to move on to another
ship better prepared for the rougher
seas that they now have to face he
equates this to his own sense of
inferiority how he doesn't feel like he
can be a valuable member to the crew how
if they can replace the going Mary they
must too be capable of replacing him
this is where usopp's motivation comes
from on the opposite side of the coin
Luffy is forced to deal with his first
big foray into what it means to be a
leader and as a captain he has to make a
very tough decision he isn't happy about
replacing Mary but if she was to be used
into the future it would be a danger to
the crew he's now responsible for this
is a non-negotiable point for either
side and what spawns from it is one of
the most emotional and character Rich
conversations and intense battles not
because the foe is mighty or some
strange monster but because as the foe
is precisely the opposite in the
conversation that takes place prior you
could hear the subtext of every word the
insecurity of us the indecisiveness and
fear in Luffy the strength Zorro gives
his captain as his number two you can
even feel it in the words Nami pleads to
both of them with this argument
threatening the very thing she's always
wanted a family it's an utterly
incredible piece of character writing
climaxing in a fashion unlike anything
we've yet seen in the series with the
straw hats fractured in a serious and
now personal way causing a butterfly
effect that creates the specific mood
and circumstances the ark contends with
moving forward it birtheds usop's
impromptu Alter Ego sniper king and the
position of the vital pieces that
outline and Define the ark as a whole
Luffy's struggle against usop is
emphasized when looked at alongside the
lengths he's willing to go to for
another in Robin it emphasizes how
difficult that conflict with usop must
have been for him and how happy he
stands to be once he returns and so if
you take anything away from this this
video and this argument I want it to be
that World building within a fight is
more than possible while also propelling
the story forward whether it be like
Dragon Ball is able to do within a fight
like with the armor of the Saiyans the
scouters spaceship and Technology Etc
not to mention Otherworld which
establishes so much on route to King Kai
that will be used from that point onward
or whether it be the state of various
personalities all at once like one piece
demonstrated neither one piece or Dragon
Ball are perfect but I hope these
examples highlight a specific issue this
Arc of bleach has I've read through all
of those other stories and I have never
seen this specific problem so massively
prominent in them knowing the good guy
will win isn't the issue it's how the
fight plays out in the same predictable
ways while offering nothing new to the
story outside of their own
self-contained segments and
personalities and knowing that it hurts
because this Arc has so many upsides
that I will most definitely discuss for
the rest of this video but had this Arc
been made more focused and refined with
a shorter page count I think it could
have easily stood to be one of the
strongest arcs in the big three and
certainly the best Arc of bleach as it
stands the Iran karak of bleach is a
staggering
247 chapters long and out of Interest
how far do you guys think that would get
you into Dragon Ball Z from its
beginning with Radix the ginu force
maybe the Frieza fight it is a long Arc
well if you had guessed that you'd have
been wrong
247 chapters into Dragon Ball Z will
plan you squarely into its final Arc of
the story towards the end of the world
tournament at that in the boo Arc and
with all of that said I am not
suggesting that no one can like this
material I am not suggesting someone
would be wrong for liking this material
all I am suggesting is that if these
characters are worthy of our respect
then they shouldn't be pigeonholed into
exception of the story contributing
little to nothing to the progression of
the narrative they should be important
it should be the case that these are
meaningful fights that changed the
course of the story but instead they
just feel like they exist solely to
create obligatory fights to show off the
10 big stronger rankers of which there
didn't need to be so many to overcome in
this story in this opening section we
have characters like ikaku which I enjoy
but again there wasn't anything
substantial he contributed Beyond
fighting an enemy that doesn't matter
then we have shuhe remember him shui you
know the kid from the flashback well yep
he's there too and then we have the
pretty eyelash guy whose name I honestly
have no idea of and finally we have
izuru I've never seen this guy before
and if you told me that this was the
first time I've seen him I would have
believed you but I get the feeling that
I should know who this person is for the
reasons I mentioned over the last 10
minutes of the video I won't be covering
their fights again not necessarily
because I didn't enjoy them or at least
parts of them and some of their
callbacks to Prior events but because I
am here to review the story and as I
said I think they get in the way of that
to a large degree for what feels like 20
plus chapters and even when it comes to
the bigger contenders like the captains
and Commander against the stronger
rankers it all just feels like it exists
only to kill time in the plotline until
Ichigo is done with his plotline in
huakamundo with ulquiora which I will
absolutely be getting to in just a
second by the way but what can I say
about this section with the captains and
the commander fighting well the artwork
in this section looks brilliant hinomori
arriving on the scene is something I
honestly didn't expect and offers up one
of the segments that serves the story in
conveying just how monstrous Eisen truly
is but then again it's consistent with
my criticism of the story that nine
times out of ten the story only
progresses when each ago is on the
screen and during that particular moment
with hinomori he is but that's not to
say there aren't good parts that don't
involve him either General Yamamoto
stepping in once things start to turn
South is if nothing else a curious
Affair for me at least we don't know
much of anything about his character
other than that he's the best so seeing
this stronger rankers and eventually
Eisen match up against this guy can be
quite compelling in a spectacle sort of
way the feeble old Ban against the
hulking monster makes for a strong
contrast but with equally but opposedly
strong contrast and strength making for
a satisfying visual finish much the same
way Goku and Krillin offered up in early
Dragon Ball and heck even in later
Dragon Ball with the likes of Gohan and
even Goku and facing Napa the smaller
more honorable Fighter versus the
brutish enemy is a tale as old as time
it's David vs Goliath's story that
always works similarly one chapter later
he enjoys the benefit of being the one
in a 1v3 affair again putting him in
what appears to be an unfavorable
situation only to subvert it again used
in countless others shown into great
effect but yeah after 20 or more
chapters of what feels like the story on
pause for the majority of the time we
eventually get back to Ichigo and
Orihime and most importantly back to
bleach delivering what it's truly
capable of
Ichigo versus ulquiora I'm going to say
it now as an individual fight of which
there aren't many in this Arc I mean
there might even be more fights in this
Arc alone than all of Dragon Ball Z but
out of all of those fights in this Arc
ukiora vs Ichigo was my favorite there
are stretches later where I thought the
story really got going and hit new Highs
but when it comes to 1v1 fights that
take place in this Arc none in my
opinion come close to touching this one
it is outstanding and probably the best
fight in the series at least that I've
seen so far firstly let me say I'm a big
fan of the way Ichigo vs ulkiora looks
the black versus white aesthetic really
suits the battle it helps both Fighters
pop and honestly helps the contest look
more straightforward to read through and
as a fight it's much more nuanced and
interesting it's not as simple as the
other fights have been because it's
directly connected to the plot in a
meaningful way there's been a concerted
effort across this Arc to deliberately
make us question more and more about
Kiora what his morals are how conflicted
he might be and as Ichigo curiously
points out after being told he's
becoming more Hollow he says to okiora
that he's becoming more human he's shown
a much more considerate side than others
in this story and if nothing else is
alongside grimjo the most interesting
antagonist introduced in this Arc
something this fight and the rest of the
Ark loves to enjoy is the awesomeness of
a certain moment it loves to bathe in
the Moonlight of a lion someone delivers
a pose someone assumes and the
transformation that naturally follows
standing in the way of Ichigo saving
orehime UL Kiora is positioned and don't
listen away
or you he pops in at the last moment to
make the save this is epic and honestly
I went nuts when I was reading it
because I was thinking at the time damn
uriu Chad Rukia they haven't added much
to this story and I kind of wish they
would and when he did I felt so much
better about his character at the very
least setting up the perfect
circumstances for ichigo's
transformation into his hollow form in
the manga which given that Kubo is The
Man Behind the pen it is stunningly
depicted
[Music]
this is the moment that starts Ichigo
down a road where we haven't yet seen
him Venture battered left and right the
Gap in power between the two of them is
clear and obvious and to add insult to
injury ulquiora has a second
transformation at any point it feels
like he has the ability to kill Ichigo
to end it here and now but he isn't
instead he seems to be more interested
in learning why Ichigo is fighting and
to which he responds I'm not fighting
because I think I can win I'm fighting
because I have to win Orihime is brought
to the Top by Urdu she sees odukiora put
a hole in Ichigo Urdu holds off ulquiora
Orihime kneels over him crying and
that's when it happens
the situation is dire Stakes are high
this is what I'm talking about she
screams for each go to help her and
[Music]
oh [ __ ] Ichigo could hear her and in an
effort to protect her this is his
response the Beast is Unleashed he
slashes off okiora's arm and uses a zero
blast it's an awesome Affair I love the
dynamic of this fight and it feels as
though at times it shares the same
appeal of something like the Frieza
fight did for me in Dragon Ball where
the hero character was being totally
outclassed by a massive magnitude only
to be pushed over the edge into
attaining a power that was unlike
anything that came before like an inner
demon of some description when he had
been reluctant to engage with has
suddenly and powerfully been released
and in the same fashion the Frieza came
to realize that discrepancy between he
and Goku so too does the significantly
more matter-of-fact and nuanced alkiora
as Ichigo utterly obliterates him
outclassing him in practically every
conceivable metric known to combat
and this this is how you weaved suffice
into your narrative this is it the story
of bleach concerns these characters and
their respective Journeys they've been
on the flow The Twist turns the
harrowing circumstances and the
ramifications of every single decision
speaks volumes about who these
characters are where their values lie
and where they will eventually end up
it's wonderful and a nice visual touch I
noticed while in this form has to be the
design of it even the ones blacked out
eyes of the previous form have now
entirely vanished All That Remains are
these dark holes in the husk of a skull
almost as if to emphasize how hollow it
is unlike the power-ups that were very
much enhancements to ichigo's current
design alterations to a mask and some
palette swaps this very much feels like
something entirely different to Ichigo
and the character with no discernible
familiar characteristics obvious for us
to see the veneer is porcelain white the
hair no longer short and spiky but
instead long flowing and straight
ruthless in nature with no Humanity Left
Behind the actions it takes the
difference it's fright okiora a hollow
made more human to achieve his power for
the sake of fulfilling another tyrant's
goals in Ichigo a human who's thrown
himself into holification Beyond a point
familiar to him in a world he's shown
genuine Terror in adapting too all for
the sake of saving the person he cares
for most oddly enough the most human
decision made is by Ichigo to distance
himself from his Humanity in this
instance with that very lack of humanity
evident for all to see
and it's at this moment as Ichigo starts
to repeat protect her protect her
protect her to himself that the pin
drops for Orihime as she realizes that
she's the one responsible for what's
transpired I think this scene while
emblematic of orohime is naivety with
regards to her decision to leave alone
in the first place it also highlights
the Stark similarities between herself
and Ichigo two sides of the same coin in
many respects in the same way Ichigo
would want to go on his own to shoulder
all of this responsibility in what would
no doubt turn out to be a suicide
mission Orihime has done the very same
with both of them being driven by
effectively each other to push
themselves into becoming better and more
helpful people capable of carrying the
weight of more and more responsibility
they in a way together are great for
each other however as we're witnessing
extreme situations with extreme actors
like this lead to extreme outcomes with
Ichigo having chosen for the immediate
safety of Orihime to lose what reason he
has left in the name of protecting her
foreign
and honestly this is my only issue with
the scene this strange desire Ichigo has
to have a fair fight with ulkiora seems
to come out of nowhere the idea that
he's doing it for the sport of it this
sense of Duty that he doesn't want to
win quote this way is a bizarre
proposition to me he's there
specifically to save those he loves from
danger now he did Express earlier that
he believed okira was becoming more
human which would hint to something
worthy of preserving that's the approach
oruhime is taking and I understand that
as I said he's been a very unique type
of a rancor to contend with in this Arc
but ichigo's reasoning that he himself
verbalizes and outlines feels like a
total cop-out like something out of
character and one that didn't need to be
there he could have just agreed with
Orihime he even pointed out earlier that
he wasn't fighting because he thinks he
can win but because he felt like he
needed to needs to because he has to
protect people but it should be obvious
that he doesn't need to fight now and so
that should have been reason enough not
to fight ulquiora once he regained his
senses not this chopping off of his own
limbs to create a fair fight that is
utterly idiotic and not to mention risks
putting the very people he came there to
save in danger it runs entirely
counter-intuitive to his underlying
motivations in other words I think it
would have been better if Ichigo came
back to life totally dead to the world
from this transformation Zapped of
energy I did however love the fear that
descended across his face once he
realizes that he had done what he did in
the Berserker form
[Music]
soil Society versus the Olympus okay so
for reasons that should be very obvious
at this point I'm not the biggest fan of
this section in karakura town either
though I will say that it is far more
enjoyable than the prelim matches we got
towards the beginning with Shuhei and
izuru or whatever his name is this is
helped mostly by us getting to see
characters we're already familiar with
fighting and we understand that they
represent a certain ceiling or ability
the back and forths that take place and
the implementation of strategy is
refreshing particularly compared to the
standard 1v1 Affair that colored the
prior section over and over and over
this time it's a 2V1 with special
conditions that make for a very
competitive cat and mouse contest
conceding how the fight itself
progresses with the variables that are
compromised and known to us ukitake and
kiraku versus the combination of two
rankers lilanet and the other one she's
the gun and can fire Sarah blast so
that's different these Dynamics these
2V1 scenarios are exactly what I was
looking for to change up at least the
visual representation of these
repetitive fights
a monstrous symbol of eisen's growing
impatience this hulking monster matches
forward into this realm greater in scope
and size than anything we've yet seen
moments past anukitake is pierced
through his abdomen kyoraku is shot from
point-blank range toshiro's opponent
escapes from her icy prison and that
aging death ranker emerges from the
smoke all the supposed progress we made
in the last dozen or so chapters has
been essentially for nothing the enemy
is monstrous and in the wake of that
upset in ruin stands Eisen tosen and gin
they have arrived but they are not the
only ones
okay I'm not gonna lie seeing these guys
I was genuinely excited however
unfortunately despite being armed with
far more knowledge surrounding hyori and
shinji's respective histories with Eisen
we once again find ourselves in a sea of
fights that offer little Beyond helping
acquaintance with certain characters
half-heartedly before defeating them I
mean I guess for these tertiary
characters getting that vacuous
Exposition is better than nothing in
terms of building the world up for later
but I still think that this Arc doesn't
do this nearly enough in situations that
have consequences for the story being
told I'd prefer a Snappy Pace to a story
of real world populated with 5 to 10
extra characters that don't offer much
of anything however that is my
preference and it's not going to be
everyone's preference so I will
acknowledge that and while this section
was less annoying than that first part
with that guy whose name I'm convinced
I've never heard before it managed to
irritate me by dangling something
genuinely interesting with potential for
story progression like Shinji vs Eisen
but then it'll cut for a ages away to
the other fights that I expressed
earlier significantly matter far less to
the story before suddenly switching back
to that interesting fight only to reveal
that Shinji isn't squaring off against
Eisen anymore but instead kin which
again still would be better and more
interesting than everything else we're
being forced to look at here
[Music]
holy [ __ ] finally some tension Shinji is
now in a situation where he desperately
wants Ichigo to get back with this crew
to heal his comrade and we know how
that's going
interestingly rookie remarks that Ichigo
seems different that his eyes have
changed and that's not the only thing
that's different it's the mask he has on
too Ichigo lands a big attack but it
only really Nicks him following this
he's unable to put the mask on again I
suspected at the time because he lacked
conviction maybe because he's conflicted
about what he has become maybe because
he has reservations now whatever the
case this won't be the last time someone
in the story remarks on the change in
ichigo's eyes and when it happens again
I'll be sure to draw attention to it
because it is valuable to the story
anyway piakuga and Kenpachi turn up and
make the save well on route we're told
that Ichigo is the only one that can
stop Eisen and this is partially due to
his not having seen Eisen shikai if he
does see it essentially he will lose
again I love this setup because it
offers a nice bit of tension a nice
stipulation and gives Ichigo a unique
purpose that others can't have by virtue
of their station meanwhile tozen
becoming a Hollow mask wearer is
interesting Shuhei stabsman head after
he is resurrected and oddly enough
becomes blinded by his own Newfound
ability to see in nice little piece of
irony there but enough of that time for
the plot
Ichigo arrives and so does the plot it
was at this point in the story that
something remarkable happened all of the
pacing issues I once complained about
totally vanished and the story was
utterly compelling I was glued to the
pages of this manga suddenly and the
contrast between that feeling of
disinterest moments prior to sudden
enthusiasm to read forced me to take a
step back and think why like why how is
it that right now I am feeling so
engaged the reader when moments prior I
wasn't and honestly this is my theory
now this isn't a hard rule but I find it
to be a very useful way of looking at
the story in order to diagnose certain
issues in storytelling typically you can
have things called the three Central
questions that once answered your story
is resolved One Professional question
one personal question and one private
question now for the sake of examples
let's take Star Wars the professional
question in that movie was Will Luke
destroy the Death Star the personal
question was will he save Princess Leia
and the private question was will he be
a Jedi like his father and when you look
at that first Star Wars film through
that lens you can clearly see that once
all of those questions have been
satisfied the story itself wraps up and
ends however keeping those questions in
mind is Paramount to the pacing of your
story too for if you aren't dealing with
one of those questions at any given time
to some degree then it can run the risk
of feeling like you're not progressing
through the story which for parts of it
is totally fine but when you deal with
large swaths of time like the Iran
characters it starts becoming more of an
issue so what are the central questions
surrounding the aranca arc well from
what I can see this is where the issue
is and oddly enough it stems from an
area Kubo is very comfortable and
confident with in writing it's Ichigo
the professional question of this Arc is
Will Ichigo be able to defeat ice the
personal question of this Arc is will he
be able to say Orihime and the private
question of this Arc is will he be able
to resolve his own internal conflicts
and if these are the central questions
what's the issue well the issue I can
see is that despite having a massive and
still growing cast of characters the
plot-central questions tend to circle
around one or if you want to push it two
characters each going maybe Eisen and I
think a massive part of what makes this
an issue is that ichigo's questions are
separated in two distinct locations
divorced from each other in important
ways in Star Wars to ensure that the
climax is satisfyingly climactic all
three of the film's central questions
are answered at once the ultimate goal
is to destroy the death stare which is
pointed at a planet that Princess Leia
is on but in order to destroy the Death
Star he needs to use the force the film
creates a set of unique circumstances
where each of those questions can only
be answered when the others are
satisfied and this created what I'm sure
few people can argue one of the most
pivotal moments in cinematic history
influencing countless other projects to
come and this isn't just true for film
let's go back to that example I used
earlier in the Saiyan Saga of Dragon
Ball Z the professional question was
will the forces of Earth protect their
Planet the personal question was Will
Gohan be able to rise to the occasion
and the private question was is Goku
stronger than Vegeta can he rise to that
challenge and what I think makes this
section of Dragon Ball work is that we
are given two equally compelling plot
lines to follow in the two different
settings the plot is split between in
other worlds we're following the journey
Goku's on to gain the power necessary to
make a difference and on Earth we're
following the story of Gohan's maturity
and development this keeps us engaged
both Within These two settings and you
can pinpoint the high points of this Arc
by keeping an eye on which questions are
teased with being answered Napa
demolishing the Earth's forces killing
Piccolo and about to stomp on Gohan is
one boot stomp away from answering two
of the potential actually three
questions with a definitive no only for
Goku to arrive and undercut that very
tension setting up the third question
Goku and Vegeta's beam struggle shows
Goku defending the Earth from an attack
that would certainly end it while also
trying to answer the question is Goku
stronger than Vegeta but the point I'm
trying to make here is throughout the
climax of this Arc in their battle with
Vegeta and Napa all of these questions
are flirted with being answered right up
until the end with the conclusion
concluding that yes they could protect
the planet yes Gohan could rise to the
occasion and technically yes Goku was
stronger than Vegeta momentarily but
once transformed he had all but lost had
it not been for Gohan bleach on the
other hand while doing what Dragon Ball
did in splitting the locations the plot
takes place between fake karakura town
and the hueco Mundo area the central
questions of the Ark can only really be
answered in hueco mundo where Ichigo is
and Eisen could in theory help this
situation but he's hardly involved at
all until the latter half of the climax
furthermore another issue I noticed
comes in the form of one of the
questions being answered long before and
entirely divorced from the Finish which
sort of makes orihime's contribution to
the arc feel a lot less significant than
I otherwise anticipated it to be can he
rescue Orihime the answer is yes and
following that Ichigo rushes off to fake
karakura town and later this is why the
battle with Eisen and his internal
struggle with himself during their first
encounter is so interesting because that
moment it's flirting with answering two
of the three remaining questions back in
fake karakura Town everyone is teaming
up against Eisen and it's actually kind
of fun to watch specifically when
shinji's ability actually starts to
disorientate Eisen
foreign
it's a great swerve and it really makes
me wish we had more of this in the story
or at least if the story was less long
it would have been more impactful
because it would have been closer to
other Great Moments after all of this
Yamamoto steps in to fight Eisen grabs
him while he stabs him and while I can
appreciate some are interested in this
matchup I can't say that I'm massively
interested we've all but been told
explicitly that Ichigo is the only one
that can defeat Eisen and I'm aware that
story isn't going to conclude or be
contributed to by Yamamoto in any
meaningful way or at least I'm fairly
certain of that I can't be sure and so
I'm just waiting for Ichigo to get
involved because as I mentioned the only
two aspects of this story yet to be
resolved in valve Ichigo and that is the
issue where the Saiyan Saga split up its
questions from the beginning between two
different characters Gohan and Goku
across two different areas Ichigo seems
to be shouldered with everything
ironically enough seeing as that's sort
of his mission to overcome that idea and
while that can work for a regular length
film like Star Wars when it comes to a
247 chapter long epic like this for the
focus to be all on one character
primarily that can create problems with
that said the Battle of yam has with
Eisen is fittingly epic in scope and
scale with the commander himself
reminding us who he really is and how
dutiful he really can be
following this Ichigo lands a
magnificent attack but Eisen reveals
that hogyoku is protecting its Master
him healing him completely in an instant
and it's here Eisen reveals that all the
growth Ichigo has undergone has occurred
within the palm of his hand thematically
chapter in 397 is a terrific move one
that makes Eisen the perfect villain for
Ichigo Kurosaki to face off against
standing before Ichigo Eisen unravels
what appears to be a complicated but
carefully curated path for Ichigo to
follow throughout his life one that
assured his own personal development as
he grew from the countless battles Eisen
placed before him all in an effort to
test him treating him like a test
subject oddly enough everything from the
moment this manga began seemingly all
occurred due to the control of Eisen his
influence and his agency and that's the
key word here agency the irankar araken
really this entire story has been about
Ichigo and the struggle he's undergone
to enact his will both onto himself and
the world around him he's consistently
coming up against foes that seem
impossible to defeat and whether it be
political decisions interpersonal
decisions or physical collisions there
has consistently been forces of work in
the story preventing Ichigo from
achieving his goal preventing him from
enacting his own agency but the story of
this manga has been that of struggle
against adversity with struggle winning
out in the end struggle in the face of
insurmountable odds to save your loved
ones to protect your friends and to in
this Arc accept and value their help the
very idea that something like this is
being propositioned by Eisen is the
Ultimate Weapon against ichigo's mind
and character it's an utter slap in the
face proposing that he's never actually
achieved anything that he's never really
made any choices but has in fact run on
a hamster wheel set up by Eisen from the
very beginning that all of this time he
thought he was winning and making a
difference in the world has been eisen's
schemes going according to plan it's a
devastating bomb to drop on Ichigo
specifically as his entire character is
built around this very idea of reacting
to challenges and overcoming them with
his own will it's one of the central
questions and one of the reasons why
this works so well for me is that it
takes two of those questions and makes
them feel impossible to overcome and
right now he's being told he never had
any agency to begin with and it's just a
chilling thought Eisen had said didn't
you ever think it was strange did you
chalk it all up to Faith did you think
that this attack was a coincidence as
well did you think your victories were
the result of your own efforts and just
as this meeting of the Minds comes to
its climax Eisen says that he's had his
eyes on Ichigo since he was born because
he's both human and
foreign
this is by far the strongest aspect and
maybe even the strongest section of the
story and can we guess why because it's
contending with most of the central
questions in this Arc Orihime is saved
so that's checked off but can he defeat
Eisen well this certainly seems to be
insurmountable the more Eisen speaks and
reveals to Ichigo and that's to ignore
the mental state he's under it's the
perfect interaction and I wish we got
more of this in the arc cause it's so
good also kind of a cool touch here uh
gin swords Bankai is perfect for his
character design I mean it should come
as no surprise to anyone that his
appearance is based on a snake I mean I
didn't mention it because I mean look at
him he's got a weird ass eyes all he
needs is a fork tongue to complete the
transformation but what's more is his
sword extends quickly to Great Lengths
in order to attack and as we find out
later leaves with it a little bit of
poison just like a snake striking like a
coiled spring I mean I don't know I
thought that was a really cute touch but
anyway back to the story
set him up once he's back and fully
formed for yoruichi to attack but to no
effect and honestly it's pretty cool
getting to see the older generation take
on Eisen and I think it's made all the
better knowing that Ichigo is present to
watch all of this unfold and during his
short-lived battle with gin Ichigo is
showing signs of uncertainty and a lack
of conviction emphasized by gin in
chapter 405 page 4 where he says were
you always this weak your mask is
brittle too is this the extent of your
holification you were scarier back then
referring to when he first clashed
swords with him during the soul Society
right now Ichigo needs to have a clear
goal to fight for back then he was
striving to reach Rukia after that he
was fighting to rescue oruhime but now
he's fighting out of a sense of Duty
when in reality that's never really been
enough for him foundationally his
character has always needed something to
fight for to get the best work out of
himself Rukia had to twist his arm back
in the day in the beginning and he
himself said that he wouldn't let
someone die in front of him when he was
first speaking on the topic in the first
Arc so basically he would need his
friends or his father or someone he
cares about to protect right now and he
doesn't really have that in an obvious
way with the mask being brittle almost
acting as a metaphor for the tenuous and
half-hearted purpose he possesses to
fight with and for in this moment and
nowhere is this tackle better than with
his most recent Venture into his mind to
confront himself in chapter 406 page 3
ichigo's father says to him the only
person who can perceive eisen's power is
someone who's in the same state he is
it's a weird thing to say in the moment
and a fact I don't know how he could
possibly verify but it matters to the
story because Ichigo can sense his
energy continuing on ichigo's dad puts
him into this state to confront zangetsu
for what might be his very last time
while Eisen arrives at the real karakura
town as his friends start to run around
the Now Quiet home they grew up in and
once inside his own mind the depiction
of zangetsu is quite different and his
words are somewhat cryptic he says I
don't care what happens to things you
want to protect and his reasoning for
feeling this way the rain that once
poured down in this world may have
stopped but now it's being sunk to the
bottom of the ocean all because you lost
hope and stopped moving forward there
are a number of strange metaphorical
interactions that take place in this
realm none of which are more striking
than ichigo's other side revealing
himself now wearing the mask of the
monster he used to protect and save
Orihime and while this is happening
Eisen is chatting with tatsuki citing
that he knows that Ichigo will show up
with some new power up once again adding
fuel to the tension surrounding ichigo's
ultimate arrival oddly enough however
something I didn't anticipate was how
hyped I would be for both kananji and
Matsumoto showing up to make the save on
a downed tatsuki following this
Matsumoto engages with gin and during
this interaction he describes himself in
a rather curious way there's always been
the similarity between gin and the snake
but the fact that he himself refers to
himself as such way back when they first
met was kind of interesting he says I'm
a snake my skin in this cold I have no
heart I Slither looking for prey with
the time of my tongue I swallow the
people I care about hope the last line
suggests that he does care about people
maybe the real gin hasn't ever really
been known to us but it exists still
deep down somewhere perhaps he didn't
kill matsumo
[Music]
holy [ __ ] okay so that was the shortest
live Theory I've ever made no joke I
swear to God I made that prediction
before reading that very part of the
chapter so I technically predicted the
moment getting turns on Eisen but albeit
in the same chapter it's revealed but
whatever it's still a cool scene but
Eisen is still in full control
foreign
the design Ichigo shows up to fight
against Eisen with is interesting sort
of like a combination of the beings that
stood in opposition to him in his mind
moments before his hair is much more
floppy than spiked and not to mention
longer his robe is in tatters with a
black chain coiled around his arm to his
fist wrapped in Black they even remarked
that he's taller so maybe it's forced
him to age up a bit and as I mentioned
with eyes being the running thing to
comment on with his appearance in this
Arc he'd mentioned that earlier he
looked weak referring to Ichigo when he
last saw him prior to his short stint
training whereas now he looked into
ichigo's eyes and says your eyes are
stronger good now I can die and leave
this in your hands and with that Ichigo
decides he wants to take this fight
elsewhere
I just thought that was really funny
it's it's really good the cam and
composed Eisen slowly over the course of
this beat down becomes tattered and
disfigured by his own inability to stop
he truly became a horrifying monster and
honestly there isn't much to this battle
I can comment on apart from the
incredible artwork but I suppose that's
a belabored point at this stage but the
truth is now that Ichigo has answered
the second question already now all that
he has to do is defeat Eisen and
naturally that does come now to be clear
I did enjoy this fight I'd even read it
again maybe but I think if all of those
Central questions instead of being
answered at gradual points across a
number of scenes in the last 50 chapters
would have better served the story had
they been answered all at once or
somewhere close together to create some
sort of Crescendo for the story but alas
it didn't quite do that alternatively it
does deliver a very satisfying Beatdown
of this weird Hollow Eisen monster
culminating on a moment where if Ichigo
uses this technique he you lose all of
his soul Reaper Powers it looks awesome
and there's a really nice message about
giving everything you have ever worked
and struggled for in the name of doing
the right thing and I think that's a
really cool thing for this act to do it
weakens Eisen tremendously but he is
still standing however urahara steps in
to weaken him further eventually Eisen
reaches the point where the whole Goku
doesn't recognize him as its master and
then reverts back to his normal State
unable to overpower those Superior to
him thus ending the threat he poses for
now I say for now because he goes to
something like the soul Society jail or
something for a comically long amount of
time and if they had no further use for
him in this story I would have thought
or I thought it would have made sense
for him to be killed off or at least
lead to his own demise so I'm going to
assume he's coming back at some point
but I mean I could be wrong stranger
things have happened uh than me being
wrong so yeah I could very well be wrong
in the aftermath of the battle however
there's a really nice piece of subtle
writing I very much appreciate it
following his transformative meeting
with tenses zangetsu he reflects on his
battle with I Horizon asking urahara in
chapter 422 page 14 and 15 did the
hogyoku really reject Eisen my dad told
me hogyoku could read the hearts of
those around it and make their wishes
come true if so maybe Eisen wanted to
lose his powers I was finally able to
feel his sword in the battle after I
gained enough power to fight him as an
equal I only felt loneliness from it if
he was born with exceptional Powers
maybe he was looking for someone who
could see things from his perspective
this has very similar wording to how his
counterparts angetsu spoke in those
interactions in his mind and using that
as the basis for this conversation it's
clear to see that interaction that
transformative experience has not only
transformed him physically but mentally
too and off the back of that to close
out this Arc there's a really touching
end to the story with Ichigo Awakening
from a month-long recovery Slumber when
he wakes rookie explains that his powers
are gone and that in moments he won't be
able to see her anymore and there's
something really sad about that and
honestly would have made for a really
nice ending to this series if not a
little melancholic just as suddenly as
she entered his life she leaves taking
with her all the spectacular and
terrifying things that brought with it
all the Adventure all the understanding
and all the Visions my suspicion at this
point now having completed this Arc is
that much the same way rookia lost her
powers but slowly regained them through
exposure to a certain environment so too
might Ichigo I mean I can't exactly
imagine he'll be without his powers for
the rest of this series I mean looking
at the amount of chapters left I he must
have powers I mean it doesn't make sense
for him not to all in all despite my
point to criticisms I did very much
enjoy this story being told during this
section the first 40 of the story is
nearly perfect and while I found far too
much blows in this final 60 percent I
still felt as though it managed to
deliver a strong final battle with Eisen
and some terrific character work with
Ichigo however similarly to Soul Society
I thought this lacked any substantial
use of its secondary car characters
Rukia played a tiny role and even
Orihime and Urdu while they played
bigger roles I thought it would have
made thematic sense for them to
contribute in some shape or form to the
conclusion of the story given how it was
framed and certainly more than the
little they ended up offering so I did
find that disappointing too I mean with
what felt like hundreds of fights in
this Arc Chad had like what two fights
with that said this concludes my review
of the iraqarak if I could describe the
Iran karak in one sentence it would be a
compelling personal story surrounding
two or three characters that ultimately
spends too much time not dealing with
these characters until the very end with
really only one getting a substantial
ending another sort of getting an ending
though I would have liked to see her get
a bit more and the third who was also
there I guess oh yeah and Chad was there
too kind of next week's video will deal
with the full bring Arc and that's
significantly shorter so hopefully
that'll work in this arc's favor until
then I've been totally not Mark and
thank you so so much for watching
[Music]
[Applause]